Jake:那就再说一遍
Jake: Then just say it again.
Jake:垃圾啊什么的
Jake: Trash and stuff.
Jake:呃就放上面这个
Jake: Uh, just put it on top here.
Jake:就是摆好陨树桌子
Jake: Just set up the tree and table.
Jake:就是要给他摆好动一下
Jake: You need to set it up properly and move it.
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Alice:没事
Alice: Nothing.
Shure: （歌词）谅我一生不羁放纵爱自由
Shure: (Lyrics) Forgive me for a lifetime of indulgence and love for freedom.
Shure: （歌词）也会怕有一天会跌倒oh no
Shure: (Lyrics) Also afraid one day I might fall, oh no.
Shure: （歌词）谁人都可以
Shure: (Lyrics) Anyone can do it.
Alice:太优雅了
Alice: So elegant.
其他人：放一首放一首
Others: Play a song, play a song.
Alice:啊微微你咋样了
Alice: Ah, Tasha, how are you doing?
Alice:哇哦好可爱
Alice: Wow, so cute.
Shure: 好OK
Shure: Okay, cool.
Shure: 呀
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 我说句话
Shure: Let me say something.
Shure: 他现在就会有点耶
Shure: He might be a bit like "yeah" now.
Shure: 哎不对
Shure: Uh, no.
Shure: 不够等一下
Shure: It's not enough, wait a second.
Shure: cowarding scent
Shure: Cowarding scent.
Shure: yeah response in the tab going in
Shure: Yeah, response in the tab going in.
Alice:这是啥呀
Alice: What's this?
Alice:哦这是一层的
Alice: Oh, it's a layer.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: novembering i feel so lonely
Shure: Novembering, I feel so lonely.
Shure: so decided gonna be my soul
Shure: So decided, gonna be my soul.
其他人：修硕你来唱我来弹
Others: Shure, you sing, I'll play.
Shure: 弹什么
Shure: Play what?
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: Sing what?
Alice:你看就是这个房间
Alice: Look, it's this room.
Alice:需要我帮忙吗
Alice: Need my help?
Tasha: 好像快收拾完了都
Tasha: Seems like almost done.
Jake:好听呵呵呵
Jake: Sounds good, haha.
Shure: 你在唱什么呀
Shure: What are you singing?
Alice:Lucy啊你好了吗
Alice: Lucia, are you done?
Lucia: 快了快了
Lucia: Almost, almost.
Alice:我的差不多了
Alice: I'm almost done.
Alice:需要我帮你吗
Alice: Need my help?
Lucia: 哈哈我快了快了
Lucia: Haha, I'm almost done.
Lucia: 那个或者可心你可以帮我把这几只鸟
Lucia: Or Katrina, can you help me with these birds?
Lucia: 就是翅膀两个翅膀尖这里都像这样子
Lucia: Just the tips of the wings, like this.
Lucia: 就你这样卷一下然后这样粘嘛
Lucia: You just roll it up a bit and then stick it.
Lucia: 它就跟双面胶一样
Lucia: It's like double-sided tape.
Lucia: 然后就可以把它粘在墙上好吗谢
Lucia: Then you can stick it on the wall, okay? Thanks.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 有一些小的我就直接撕开贴了
Lucia: Some of the small ones, I'll just tear off and stick them.
Lucia: 因为那些小的我觉得肯肯定能撕下来
Lucia: Because I think the small ones can definitely be torn off.
Lucia: 但是像大一点的就不敢这样贴
Lucia: But for the bigger ones, I don't dare to stick them like that.
Lucia: 谢谢可心
Lucia: Thanks, Katrina.
Lucia: 我马上就回来
Lucia: I'll be right back.
Shure: 我们的志愿者先生
Shure: Our volunteer mister.
Alice:好热呀
Alice: It's so hot.
Shure: so hot
Shure: So hot.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Alice:安康鱼
Alice: Anglerfish.
Alice:康鱼康安
Alice: Anglerfish, Angler.
Shure: 其实那俩字不发音就不就是安康
Shure: Actually, if you don't pronounce those two characters, it's just "Ankang".
Shure: 那是鱼字旁
Shure: It's the fish radical.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello?
Shure: hello
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello?
Shure: 耶
Shure: Yay!
Shure: 回向拉满
Shure: Full return.
Lucia: 谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 非常感谢
Lucia: Really appreciate it.
Lucia: 感觉胜利在望
Lucia: Feels like victory is in sight.
Lucia: 那个鱼哎呀就不做了
Lucia: That fish, oh well, let's not do it.
Lucia: 我就直接把它放在那就行
Lucia: I'll just put it there.
Tasha: 变了没
Tasha: Did it change?
Alice:hello Lucy啊
Alice: Hello, Lucia!
Lucia: hello
Lucia: Hello.
Alice:这是啊你的好可爱
Alice: This is so cute.
Lucia: 谢谢我的梳子
Lucia: Thanks, it's my comb.
Alice:好像花枝脚的风格
Alice: It looks like a floral design.
Lucia: 这个好像是
Lucia: This one seems like it.
Lucia: 反正这个有一段时间特别火
Lucia: Anyway, it was really popular for a while.
Alice:花西子
Alice: Florasis.
Alice:可爱
Alice: Cute.
Alice:感觉你会魔法
Alice: It feels like you can do magic.
Lucia: 哎我就是会魔法
Lucia: Yeah, I can do magic.
Lucia: 你看的非常准确
Lucia: You guessed it right.
Lucia: 我其实是一个魔法魔法魔法
Lucia: Actually, I am a magic, magic, magic...
Lucia: 魔法什么呀
Lucia: What magic?
Lucia: 魔法少女
Lucia: Magical girl.
Alice:魔法少者使者
Alice: Magical envoy.
Alice:这小鱼好可爱
Alice: This little fish is so cute.
Lucia: 对本来想把它挂在渔网里的
Lucia: Yeah, I was going to put it in the fishing net.
Lucia: 然后发现
Lucia: Then I found out...
Alice:太沉了吧
Alice: It’s too heavy, right?
Lucia: 对然后就把它放在那了
Lucia: Yeah, so I just left it there.
Alice:慢慢理解世界
Alice: Slowly understanding the world.
Alice:慢慢更新自己
Alice: Slowly updating oneself.
Lucia: 然后这个床还要铺一下好烦啊
Lucia: And I still need to make this bed, so annoying.
Alice:hello
Alice: Hello.
Alice:我们不需要先把它倒一波吗
Alice: Don’t we need to pour it out first?
Alice:下午不是还要录吗
Alice: We need to record again in the afternoon, right?
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 等康康说了再再说吧
Shure: Let’s wait for Kang Kang to tell us.
Shure: conshion
Shure: Conshion.
Alice:杨老板这个要不要先导一波呀
Alice: Jake, should we pour this out first?
Alice:下午还录吗
Alice: Are we recording in the afternoon?
Jake:下下午当然录好了
Jake: Of course, we are recording in the afternoon.
Jake:现在还有多少
Jake: How much is left now?
Alice:现在还有
Alice: Right now...
Jake:还有多少
Jake: How much is left?
Alice:40.77
Alice: 40.77
Jake:还有一个小时可以
Jake: We have an hour left, it’s fine.
Jake:等一个小时我们就倒呗
Jake: Let’s pour it out in an hour.
Alice:好但是现在12点半了
Alice: Okay, but it’s already 12:30.
Jake:等到饭来
Jake: Let’s wait until lunch arrives.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:倒一个小时吧
Jake: Pour it out in an hour.
Alice:遥控器呢
Alice: Where’s the remote?
Shure: 这是你的新的MacBook
Shure: This is your new MacBook.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Right?
其他人：黑色的卧槽
Others: It’s black, wow.
其他人：这黑色的人家是
Others: This black one is...
其他人：高高贵的黑色
Others: Noble black.
Shure: 就是他从M3开始才有黑色的
Shure: It was only from the M3 model that they started having black ones.
其他人：我新买的我还没配呢
Others: I just bought it, I haven't set it up yet.
其他人：先给我看一下
Others: Let me see it first.
其他人：你别配啊
Others: Don't set it up yet.
其他人： 人家买的黑色的啊
Others: They bought the black one.
Lucia: 你那个用美纹胶粘的吗
Lucia: Did you use masking tape for that?
其他人：好看吗
Others: Does it look good?
Jake:刚刚取了20个快递
Jake: I just picked up 20 packages.
其他人：卧槽这联网还有点问题
Others: Damn, there's a network issue.
其他人：这个会有切换输入法的问题吗
Others: Will there be problems with switching input methods?
其他人：有啊
Others: Yes.
其他人：都有
Others: There are.
其他人：只要是苹果都
Others: It's the same for all Apple devices.
其他人：现在退还来的及吗
Others: Can I still return it now?
其他人：怎么了
Others: What's wrong?
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's up?
其他人：我说现在退还来的急吗
Others: I mean, can I still return it now?
其他人：别搞你搞不出来的
Others: Don't try, you won't manage it.
其他人：你可以把它平铺到这上面斜边珠
Others: You can lay it flat on this and align the beads diagonally.
Shure: 单线城
Shure: Single-track mind.
Shure: 就脑子里面只有一个一个目标是吧
Shure: Your mind is fixated on just one goal, right?
Shure: 钢琴他都弹不好
Shure: He can't even play the piano well.
Shure: 这心乱了
Shure: His mind is a mess.
Shure: 当然可以啦
Shure: Of course you can.
Jake:我贴这儿
Jake: I'll stick it here.
Jake:然后贴一排
Jake: Then stick a row.
Jake:你就几个呀
Jake: How many do you have?
Shure: 也许
Shure: Maybe.
其他人：快弹高潮
Others: Play the climax.
Shure: （歌词）愿意
Shure: (Lyrics) Willing
Shure: （歌词）如果全世界
Shure: (Lyrics) If the whole world
其他人：操
Others: Damn.
Shure: 还有个桥吗这
Shure: Is there a bridge here?
Shure: （歌词）不去珍惜
Shure: (Lyrics) Not to cherish
Shure: （歌词）而你在这里我总记得在哪里
Shure: (Lyrics) And you're here, I always remember where
Shure: （歌词）如果全世界我也可以忘记
Shure: (Lyrics) If I could forget the whole world
Shure: （歌词）至少还有你值得我去珍惜
Shure: (Lyrics) At least there's you worth cherishing
Shure: （歌词）你相信那是生命的奇迹
Shure: (Lyrics) Do you believe that’s the miracle of life
其他人：哎你们那个电脑不是黑的吗
Others: Hey, aren't your computers black?
Shure: 我们都是深空灰的其实
Shure: Actually, we all have space gray ones.
Shure: 不是就是整个颜色就是不一样
Shure: No, the color is just different.
Shure: 我们是灰的你这
Shure: Ours is gray and yours is...
Shure: 不一样你在光下面看
Shure: It's different when you look at it under the light.
Shure: 就啊你看你放着
Shure: See, look when you place it here.
Shure: 对比下这俩色
Shure: Compare these two colors.
Shure: 这是深空灰
Shure: This is space gray.
其他人：确实黑一点
Others: It is indeed a bit darker.
其他人：黑的好看
Others: The black one looks good.
Shure: 确实显大气
Shure: It indeed looks more elegant.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure: 对里面都是一样的
Shure: The inside is all the same.
Shure: 插口也是一样
Shure: The ports are also the same.
Shure: 我说插口也都是一样的
Shure: I'm telling you, the ports are all the same.
Shure: 而且黑色的都显大感觉
Shure: And the black one looks bigger.
其他人： 肯定给我买黑的
Others: Surely, get me the black one.
Jake:哎呦我操
Jake: Oh my god.
其他人：我靠不是
Others: No way.
Shure: 红尘客栈
Shure: Red Dust Inn.
其他人：对这两个一模一样
Others: Yeah, these two are exactly the same.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 怎么要的东西这么多呢
Shure: Why do you have so many things?
Shure: 怎么野花
Shure: What's with the wildflowers?
Shure: 家花哪有野花香是吗
Shure: Aren't wildflowers more fragrant than garden flowers?
Shure: 你给他端起来放这顶吧
Shure: Lift it up and place it on top here.
Shure: 谢斌竹来来来
Shure: Xie Binzhu, come here.
Shure: 谢明珠谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Mingzhu, Xie Binzhu.
其他人：哎靖康
Others: Hey, Jingkang.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
其他人：借个充电宝
Others: Can I borrow a power bank?
Jake:当然不能拔啊
Jake: Of course, you can't just unplug it.
其他人：他拿走充眼镜去了
Others: He took it to charge his glasses.
Jake:那在不能拿走
Jake: Then you can't take it away.
Shure: 哎压了压了压了压了
Shure: Hey, it's pressing down, it's pressing down.
Tasha: 不能拿走不好意思我靠那是充摄像头的是吗
Tasha: You can't take it away, sorry. Is that for charging the camera?
Jake:啊
Jake: Yeah.
其他人：对对对
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure: 你瞅着点
Shure: Keep an eye on it.
其他人：你拿那个方的那个
Others: Take the square one.
Shure: 你底下看着点
Shure: Watch the bottom.
Tasha: 这充摄像头啊
Tasha: This is for charging the camera?
其他人：这个而且这个也不好携带
Others: And it's not very portable either.
Jake:我我下去给你拿一个
Jake: I'll go get you one.
Jake:我看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Jake:你你这个还有多少电
Jake: How much battery do you have left?
Alice:80
Alice: 80.
Jake: 80
Jake: 80.
Jake:眼镜上面呢
Jake: How about on the glasses?
Alice:100
Alice: 100.
Alice:有人用这个吗
Alice: Is anyone using this?
Alice:要不先用这个
Alice: How about we use this first?
其他人：这么好看的吗
Others: Is it this nice?
其他人：参观一下
Others: Let's take a look around.
其他人：我靠这样非常的复古
Others: Wow, this looks really vintage.
Jake:楼下怎么样啊
Jake: How's downstairs?
Jake:现在干净吗
Jake: Is it clean now?
Shure: 只能说八成干净
Shure: It's about 80% clean.
其他人：非常干净
Others: Very clean.
Jake:哈哈你们这
Jake: Haha, you guys...
Tasha: 众口难调
Tasha: Different opinions.
Jake:呵
Jake: Heh.
其他人：我反正看非常干净
Others: I think it's really clean anyway.
Jake:外边呢
Jake: How about outside?
其他人：也非常干净
Others: Also very clean.
Jake:干净个球赶紧出去
Jake: Clean my foot, hurry up and get out.
Tasha: 买的
Tasha: Bought it.
其他人：买的
Others: Bought it.
其他人：为啥
Others: Why?
其他人：然后你昨天不在这附近
Others: And you weren't around here yesterday?
其他人：咋了被劫者说
Others: What happened? Did someone get robbed?
其他人：嗯
Others: Hmm.
其他人：没事
Others: It's fine.
Jake:把那个外面收拾收拾吧嗯
Jake: Clean up the outside a bit, okay?
其他人：楼下
Others: Downstairs.
Jake:对楼下外头
Jake: Yes, downstairs outside.
Jake:刘帅干嘛呢
Jake: Choiszt, what are you doing?
其他人：啊我在调试
Others: Ah, I'm adjusting.
Jake:下去哈哈
Jake: Go downstairs, haha.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
Shure: 哦我的好像满了
Shure: Oh, mine seems to be full.
Jake:你看看是不是满了
Jake: Check if it's full.
Jake:我觉得不是满了
Jake: I don't think it's full.
Shure: 因为他灯是亮的
Shure: Because the light is on.
Jake:crashed那就再restart
Jake: If it crashed, then restart.
其他人：一会儿咱吃饭在二楼
Others: We'll eat on the second floor later.
Jake:吃饭在二楼
Jake: Eat on the second floor.
其他人：那在二楼怎么吃啊
Others: How do we eat on the second floor?
Jake:那就一楼吧
Jake: Then the first floor.
Jake:一楼一楼一楼一楼一楼
Jake: First floor, first floor, first floor, first floor.
Jake:总有地方能吃
Jake: There will be a place to eat.
其他人：我把桌子收一下
Others: I'll clean up the table.
其他人：别弹了谢斌竹
Others: Stop playing, Xie Binzhu.
Jake:哪个老板顶饿
Jake: Which boss can endure hunger?
Jake:哈哈哈哦
Jake: Hahaha, oh.
Shure: 杨老板说你为什么
Shure: Jake says, why are you...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 我靠怎么这么远
Shure: Damn, why is it so far?
其他人：马上用斯坦福的钢琴给大家弹
Others: I'll play the piano from Stanford for everyone.
Tasha: 斯坦福
Tasha: Stanford?
其他人：必须的 800万
Others: Of course, 8 million.
Tasha: 不是施坦威吗
Tasha: Isn't it Steinway?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake:完了完了完了完了都录上了
Jake: Oh no, oh no, it's all recorded.
Shure: 露怯了
Shure: Got exposed.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:what should i do
Jake: What should I do?
Jake:哎哟好看
Jake: Oh wow, looks good.
Jake:我的这个在哪儿啊
Jake: Where's mine?
其他人：你连上了是吧
Others: You're connected, right?
Shure: 连上了
Shure: Connected.
其他人：那我把我的声音关了
Others: Then I'll mute my sound.
Shure: 来吧用
Shure: Come on, use it.
其他人：我操
Others: Damn.
其他人：卧槽
其它人：卧槽
Shure: 卧槽哈哈好
Shure: Damn, haha, good.
Jake:这能吃吗
Jake: Can this be eaten?
其他人：啊
Jake:真的就一个吗
其他人：能吃真的
Jake:问问啊问问
其他人：为啥问问能不能吃啊
Shure: 呵呵呵你别一脸高潮的样子好吗
其他人：批准了
Jake:批准了我操
其他人：这个你吃吗
Jake:这我不吃
Jake:吃不动了
Jake:今天要吃很多的你知道吗
Jake:啊今天要吃很多的
Jake:因为要做很多
其他人：为什么
其他人：今天还要做啊少做点
Jake:吃不动我饿
其他人：这个就半个
Jake:晚上吃不吃
Jake:这个叫半个
Jake: This is called half.
Jake:你拿别人吃
Jake: You're taking someone else's food.
其他人：他们都不吃我靠
Others: They won't eat it, oh my gosh.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
其他人：死活也不吃
Others: They absolutely refuse to eat it.
其他人：那我吃了
Others: Then I'll eat it.
Jake:没有
Jake: No way.
Tasha: 算了
Tasha: Forget it.
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's no way at all.
Shure: （歌词）没有一点点防备
Shure: (lyrics) Not even a little bit prepared.
Shure: （歌词）也没有一丝顾虑
Shure: (lyrics) Not even a bit worried.
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What are you going to do?
Jake:马上马上很快很快
Jake: Soon, very soon.
Shure: 垫个垫应该更高一点哎
Shure: Adding a cushion should make it higher.
Shure: 又舒服了
Shure: Much better now.
Shure: 斯坦福你弹的是斯坦福钢琴
Shure: Stanford, you're playing a Stanford piano.
Jake:就凭这句话你就得有一只offer
Jake: Just for saying that, you should get an offer.
Jake:录下来了
Jake: Got it recorded.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh man.
Jake:你怎么这么多东西
Jake: Why do you have so much stuff?
其他人：我们这斯坦福这么叼
Others: Our Stanford is that awesome.
Jake:贴哪了贴哪
Jake: Where did you stick it?
Tasha: 好看吗
Tasha: Does it look good?
其他人：完了修硕
Others: It's over, Shure.
其他人：练了大半个大一的记了
Others: You spent most of your freshman year practicing.
Shure: 他好像有阅读模式吧
Shure: It seems like it has a reading mode.
Shure: 他没有显示阅读器
Shure: It doesn't show a reader.
Shure: 你可以把他这单独放大
Shure: You can enlarge it separately.
Shure: 这样
Shure: Like this.
Shure: 哒哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da da da.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 空调遥控器在哪呢
Shure: Where's the air conditioner remote?
Jake:你可以开了
Jake: You can turn it on.
Jake:收拾完可以开了
Jake: After cleaning, you can turn it on.
其他人：yeah
Others: Yeah.
Shure: 我们是不是收拾完之后一起做蛋糕了
Shure: Should we make a cake together after cleaning up?
Jake:吃完之后吃饭
Jake: After that, have a meal.
Jake:做蛋糕差不多对就结了
Jake: Making a cake sounds good, let's finish it.
Jake:是吧把这把
Jake: Right, let's...
Jake:这可能摆摆摆
Jake: Maybe arrange this...
Jake:椅子稍微摆摆
Jake: Move the chairs a bit.
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello?
Jake:哎好好好好好好
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay.